مع تصاعد الاحتجاجات في انحاء ايران ومات
لها من حمله قمع نفذتها قوات الامن باتت
الحكومه تركز كثيرا على اغلاق المواقع
وايضا الصفحات المناهضه للسلطات على
الانترنت ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن
في الكواليس يشعر البعض بالقلق من ان
الحكومه تستخدم التكنولوجيا بطريقه اخرى
وتتمثل في قرصنه واختراق تطبيقات الهاتف
الجوال لمراقبه بمراقمع المعارضه كشفت
احدى المحتجزات في سجن ايفين الشهير بشمال
طهران كشفت لشبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه ان
السلطات اخترقت حساباتها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فتشت في المحادثات
والرسائل النصيه الخاصه بها لتوريتها في
جرائم بعينها طبعا بحسب سي ان فقط هددت
السلطات الفتاه المحتجزه اثناء استجوابها
بان مصيرها سيكون الاعدام حيث تواجه
اتهامات باداره بمجموعه ناشطه مناهضه
للنظام على تطبيق تيليجرام وهو طبعا ادعاء
فيه الفتاه تعتقد الفتاه الايرانيه ان
عملاء ايرانيين اخترقوا حساب تيليجرام
الخاص بها في يوليو الماضي اثناء وجودها
في السجن على حد قولها حيث اعاده السلطات
تنشيطه حسابها على التطبيق لمعرفه من حاول
الاتصال بها والكشف عن النشطاء السياسيين
الذين كانت على تواصل معهم يحذر نشطاء
حقوق الانسان من قدره النظام الايراني على
اختراقه هواتف المتظاهرين والمعارضين
والوصول الى الصور والبيانات وسجلات
والمكالمات وغيرها من المعلومات الشخصيه
الهامه وذلك عن بعد